[Música]
millones de personas Se tomaron las
calles de diferentes ciudades de Francia
en la que sería la sexta y más reciente
jornada de manifestaciones contra el
proyecto de ley presentado por el
gobierno del presidente Manuel macó el
proyecto Busca aumentar la edad de
jubilación en Francia de 62 a 64 años
pero cuenta con un enorme rechazo por
parte de algunos partidos de la
oposición y también de la opinión
pública la reforma pues Tal parece que
no tuvo mucho éxito en su paso por la
asamblea y ahora después de un intenso
debate intenta ganar la aprobación en el
senado francés de acuerdo con las
encuestas recientes un tercio de los
franceses está de acuerdo con esta
reforma que permitiría que el sistema
francés de pensiones quede un poco más
parecido a los de otros países europeos
en cuanto a la edad oficial para
pensionarse en más detalles en el
siguiente reporte que organizaron en la
redacción de France 24
un texto que genera un descontento a
gran escala según El Ejecutivo el
objetivo es restablecer el equilibrio
financiero del sistema de pensiones por
lo que propone las siguientes medidas la
edad legal de jubilación pasará
gradualmente de los 62 años actuales a
64 en 2030 es precisamente este punto el
que causa mayor descontento veo a mi
alrededor en muchas profesiones que hay
gente que está completamente agotada
incluso antes de los 60 años entonces
qué pasará si ampliamos el límite de
edad a los 64
los trabajadores nacidos a partir de
1964 tendrán que cotizar 43 años en
lugar de 42 para jubilarse mientras que
la edad máxima de jubilación para las
guerreras incompletas se mantienen 77
años para una pensión completa el
gobierno afirma que la reforma tiene en
cuenta la realización del trabajo en
circunstancias excepcionales pero una de
las críticas es que el texto castiga a
las personas con trabajos penosos porque
les será más difícil trabajar más tiempo
en el transporte hay transporte pero
también hay mudanzas hay muchos trabajos
en los que hay mucha manipulación es un
trabajo duro se imaginan a un trabajador
de mudanzas a sus 64 años bajando un
piano de un cuarto piso no es concebible
la reforma de las pensiones también
prevé el fin de los regímenes especiales
que benefician a los trabajadores de
algunas grandes empresas públicas como
las Industrias eléctricas y del gas O el
banco de Francia el gobierno también
quiere crear un índice sobre el empleo
de las personas mayores un dispositivo
para controlar la situación de los
trabajadores al final de su carrera en
las empresas según El Ejecutivo el
beneficio de la Reforma de las pensiones
se ha estimado en 17,000 millones de
euros en 2030
el gobierno del presidente Manuel macón
defiende su propuesta bajo el argumento
de garantizar un sistema francés de
jubilación óptimo en el futuro cercano
que se mantenga un sistema de equilibrio
también es una de las grandes apuestas
pero sobre todo el gobierno no quiere
tener que imponer este proyecto por vía
decreto conseguirá Entonces el consenso
entre los ciudadanos será aprobado en el
senado francés Mako negociará con los
sindicatos que han salido a las calles a
manifestarse las centrales obreras van a
conseguir paralizar el país y lograrán
tener entonces a los ciudadanos de su
lado hoy en el debate de France 24 la
Reforma pensional en discordia en
Francia y para analizar este tema hemos
invitado a María José zorrilla ella es
analista política Master en cooperación
y desarrollo internacional ella se
encuentra en la ciudad de París en
Francia y también allí en la capital
francesa se encuentra
él es analista internacional y
doctorante en economía en el centro de
investigación y de documentación sobre
las Américas en la universidad lazo
ustedes también nuestros televidentes
hacen parte de este debate pueden dejar
sus comentarios y sus preguntas a través
de las redes sociales estamos en Twitter
en Facebook y también en instagram
ustedes ya lo saben no se encuentran
como arroba
franz24_es la etiqueta para que dejen
los comentarios numeral el debate f24 y
a mí me encuentran en Twitter como
arroba santilogo no olviden también que
todos los contenidos del programa están
disponibles en Apple podcast en Spotify
en deezer y en TuneIn
Bueno pues comienzo dándole la
bienvenida a María José en la ciudad de
París María José gracias por estar con
nosotros en el programa sexta jornada de
manifestaciones qué significado a nivel
político tiene esta sexta jornada que ha
paralizado prácticamente al país a
Francia en diferentes sectores Cuál es
su opinión
Muchas gracias por la información
Santiago bueno como estábamos comentando
justamente Me parece que hay Demasiada
información técnica y que justamente las
personas en general la ciudadanía Está
tratando de posicionarse o entre
justamente Pro o esta reforma o contra
esta reforma yo creo que definitivamente
hay un trasfondo mayor que simplemente
saber
a qué edad las personas se van a se van
a retirar creo que hay una un
una suerte de una dimensión de Justicia
social que claro la primera ministra
mencionó bien cuando cuando anunció este
este sistema de reformas pero creo que
también hay esta esta esta dimensión de
Justicia social en donde se tiene donde
diferentes sectores de la población de
diferentes sectores de la ciudadanía
están buscando justamente
hundir a diferentes sectores de la
población como hablamos de como vamos a
hablar más adelante también sobre los
movimientos de la mujer y también se
habla bastante de la calidad de trabajo
y pues pues de nuevo la la vuelta a la
normalidad con con lo del covid y la
pandemia
ya en la ciudad de París también le doy
la bienvenida Gracias por estar con
nosotros y también el mismo Punto de
partida la misma pregunta para comenzar
una sexta jornada de manifestaciones
allí en Francia diferentes sectores
bloqueados allí en el país Qué
significado tiene esto a nivel político
antes de entrar en materia en la reforma
sí Hola buen día y gracias por por la
invitación
sí como hemos comentado un poco podemos
ver que
que es esa sexta jornada de movilización
se caracterizó por una la más amplia
tasa de de movilización desde
que el gobierno anunció
esa voluntad de adoptar esa reforma de
la jubilación porque tenemos
según los sindicatos tenemos como tres
punto cinco millones de personas
movilizadas y según el gobierno se
corresponde a más o menos 1.28 millones
de personas
hay una diferencia grande entre esas dos
estimaciones pero pero lo que demuestra
es que se trata de Finalmente de las
tasas de movilización más importantes
si tomamos todas las movilizaciones
sociales tuvieron lugar en Francia desde
1995 el suro hemos visto ese esa tasa de
movilización en 2010 y era también para
una previa reforma de la jubilación que
que que que conducía a hacer la dieta de
jubilación de 60 años a 62 Entonces sí
me parece que traduce un derecho a su
importante de estar Reforma por varias
razones en su vida más hablar de eso más
allá
uno de los puntos como lo decía el
reportaje previo a darle paso a la
presentación de ustedes los invitados es
el tema de la edad de jubilación pasar
de 62 a 64 los argumentos desde los
sindicatos Y es de los lados ciudadanos
son en varios pero por qué genera tanto
rechazo esta este aumento en la de
jubilación entre la sociedad francesa
cuando si uno lo compara con otros
países de la Unión Europea Francia
está un poco por debajo del promedio del
bloque comunitario
lo que pasa principalmente es que uno de
los argumentos que que
utilizan los sindicatos es que
ese criterio de la edad es el criterio
que podemos considerar como lo más
Injusto porque porque significa que
cualquier sea La La La La La La La La
profesión la posición de las personas
tienen que trabajar Al menos hasta 64
años lo que podría
perjudiciales Perdón en mayoría las
personas que que trabajan en empleos que
están considerados como complicados
físicamente o que con la debilidad
importante porque esas personas en
general empezar a trabajar más joven que
otras personas
que pueden ser más calificadas y que
tienen empleo
de los argumentos que que están que los
sindicatos ponen en luz y además
tenemos un parte de la oposición de
izquierda o los indicadores que que
explican que ahora un trabajador en
Francia produce cuatro veces más que
Durante los años 70 entonces explican
que que estaré formando
No no es tan necesaria de este punto de
vista y
Y si pudimos también
justo un último punto y ya pero lo que
lo que pasa También es que el consejo de
orientación de las pensiones que es un
organismo público que que está encargado
de evaluar las modalidades de
financiación de las pensiones en Francia
ponen luz el hecho de que si el sistema
se mantiene como tal Durante los 10
próximos años finalmente podrá llegar
un balance financiero dentro de diez
años entonces si Esos son los mayores
argumentos
María José
cualquiera de usted que entonces es aquí
la la función que tiene que tener el
gobierno o que ha tenido el gobierno
Hasta ahora ha fallado el gobierno del
presidente macó en dar a explicar estos
puntos y estas reforma necesaria el
sistema de pensiones porque como dice
nuestro otro invitado en una proyección
de unos diez años el sistema puede
empezar a desfinanciarse y Podría
empezar a ver una especie de colapso
dentro del sistema de pensiones aquí se
está previendo justamente que eso llegue
a suceder porque el gobierno ha fallado
entonces en la comunicación o en la
explicación de este de este proyecto
yo creo que sí y no sí porque claramente
el gobierno ha señalado que bueno ha
recordado más bien que
esto Esta reforma de del sistema de
pensiones ha sido uno de las promesas de
campaña Entonces yo creo que de cierta
forma no ha fallado a las personas que
votaron por ellos pero bueno eh Y por
otro lado eh Sí sí les ha fallado porque
hasta ahora Bueno hasta este momento ya
es la sexta jornada de manifestaciones
eh No el gobierno no muestra señales de
de empatía o de querer conversar
justamente con diferentes sectores de la
población que justamente son sectores
bastante vulnerables como lo
decían justamente hay los sectores más
más vulnerables de la población son los
que justamente gracias a esta bueno
gracias a esta reforma van a ser aún más
vulneralizados como son pues las
personas jóvenes y
pues las mujeres también por qué
recorremos que
ya que ellas Bueno una parte una parte
de esta población tiene ciertos bajas de
maternidad Entonces eso significa que
van a tener que trabajar muchísimo más
tiempo con un par de meses más para que
puedan recién Acceder al sistema de
pensiones
importante ese punto María José continuó
con usted para entender también Dentro
de este contexto actual estas campañas
también los movimientos sindicales los
movimientos ciudadanos y desde el
gobierno y desde la oposición han hecho
uso de redes sociales y de medios de
comunicación para difundir aquí
diferentes ideas este
este proyecto en particular ha sido
presa de la desinformación es decir Hoy
vemos a más de un millón de personas en
las calles y algunos de ellos presa de
la desinformación en cuanto a lo que
contiene esta reforma o Aquí la gente de
verdad está convencida que la reforma no
les conviene a nivel social
yo creo que como expliqué un poco al
inicio hay como dos retóricas que
intentan ganar Pues a la mayor parte de
la población está las personas que están
Pro esta reforma que normalmente pues
son economistas o personas el gobierno
en general eh Y claro tenemos el lado de
los que están en contra de la Reforma
son normalmente los partidos de
izquierda en diferentes diversos
sectores de la población entonces creo
que en general la ciudadanía en general
está
Está bueno ya sabemos Claro que siete
Siete de cada diez franceses se oponen
esta reforma y justamente Yo creo que el
gobierno lo sabe y
acepta este costo este costo político de
la reforma y pues creo que es
interesante saber o preguntarse porque
justamente el gobierno de Manuel macron
o por qué específicamente macron a pesar
de esta de este descontento de la
población sigue
sigue con esta reforma creo que no
solamente se queda en términos
económicos demográficos sino también hay
una estrategia ahí de macrón a nivel
europeo porque bueno recordemos que esta
ya va a ser la la última el último
gobierno de macron en su segundo
gobierno Entonces no se puede reelegir y
me parece que claro tiene algunas miras
quizás a a escalar quizás en algún
puesto importante como alto comisionario
en la Unión Europea Pero bueno quizá
podemos hablar eso más adelante Claro
ese tema lo vamos a mirar más adelante
María José dejémoslo sobre la mesa del
costo político que tiene esto para el
gobierno del presidente
majó
con usted leyendo un poco la prensa
francesa y Mirando algunas de las
declaraciones que daban los
manifestantes en las calles de París en
la capital muchos han coincidido en
decir que esta sexta manifestación esta
sexta jornada de manifestaciones
significa una nueva fase en en este
descontento social que no viene
solamente por el tema de el proyecto de
ley de la Reforma del sistema de
pensiones en el gobierno pasado el
presidente macón vimos las
manifestaciones de los chalecos
amarillos por diferentes motivos pero
aquí hablan de una nueva fase de qué
fase están hablando y cuáles son las
características que va a tener esa nueva
fase de descontento entre los franceses
si lo que es interesante es que esa
movilización parece agregar
diferentes diferentes elementos de
derecho de la política puesta puesta en
el chat por el gobierno de de macron y
y creo que sí cuando hablan de esa
neurosis justamente a propósito de esa
tasa de participación que parece más
amplia que
que antes y que hemos podido ver desde
los años 90 Finalmente y que podría
representar una una forma de de de de de
de depresión según ellos que podría
conducir el gobierno a cambiar su
posición en ese tema pero
vamos a ver también lo que pasa en a
nivel de las instituciones
parlamentarias en Francia tal vez vamos
a
eso un poco más allá pero pero ahora el
proyecto de ley está en discusión en el
senado en Francia porque porque el
gobierno si decidió adoptar una
apoyarse en el artículo 471 de la
Constitución que permite discutir más
rápidamente algunos proyectos de de
ellas específicas que que son
Y entonces si el senado está discutiendo
esto normalmente Debería ser adoptado en
el senado porque
la la derecha el partido el mayor
partido de derecha francés está tiene la
mayoría
está a favor de de ese proyecto y
después va a ser una otra fase en la
cual
una comisión paritaria va a reunir
senadores y diputados para para intentar
obtener un compromiso una forma de de
compromiso antes de un último voto en la
asamblea nacional Entonces eso va a ser
si vamos
en cuanto al trámite que tiene que tener
esta propuesta a nivel en el legislativo
Francés pero vuelvo a la pregunta
inicial María José Qué significa para
este malestar Social para los franceses
Este término que coincide en varios en
decir en las calles que están en una
nueva fase A qué se refieren a
confrontar al gobierno a tratar de hacer
ver que no están de acuerdo con esta
reforma pensional con una huelga que hay
que decir va a ser indefinida comenzó
hoy y puede extenderse a lo largo de
varios días y que también se une a unas
manifestaciones que están
preparadas en diferentes ciudades
francesas con motivo de el día
internacional
de la mujer
claro yo creo que de ambos bandos donde
ambos lados sinceramente van a van a
seguir
lo que ya ya han planteado o sea ambos
sectores por un lado tenemos claro al
sector de los manifestantes que van a
van a seguir y van a seguir manifestando
y claro yo he escuchado algunos análisis
de que quizás podamos ver un
resurgimiento de los chalecos amarillos
otras otros que quizás van a estar
negociando con el gobierno entonces
realmente es un poco incierto por ese
lado y por el lado del gobierno la
verdad es que yo veo que no no van a dar
no van a retroceder O sea no no no me
parece que por el momento Emmanuel
macron vaya a querer negociar con con
este sector ahora la población lo que sí
sé es que se va a reunir con sarcósis Me
parece que mañana quien es líder de los
republicanos entonces va a estar
buscando más bien el apoyo de la de la
mayoría
de la mayoría en la asamblea para
justamente hacer pasar esta esta reforma
entonces me parece que del lado del
gobierno ellos van a intentar
Buscar apoyo y concertación pero con no
con el sector de la población que
realmente deberían claro Entonces eso
justamente deja por fuera de la ecuación
una posible mesa de diálogo entre
manifestantes o sindicatos con el
gobierno para tratar de encontrar un
punto en común en cuanto a la reforma
Ustedes han mencionado aquí un punto
importante y es Buscar apoyos al
interior del legislativo
qué tantos apoyos cuenta Esta reforma al
interior del senado veíamos que en la
asamblea no le fue así como muy bien los
mismos franceses lo han calificado como
que pasó
con menos con más negativas que
positivas pero en el senado las cosas
son completamente diferentes Cómo están
las cargas allí y hago esta pregunta que
puede ser muy básica para ustedes pero
para la audiencia en Latinoamérica que
no conoce bien la composición del del
parlamento francés pues es importante
para ver qué trayectoria va a tener esta
reforma a futuro
si eso es interesante porque podemos ver
que en la asamblea nacional
el macroismo sea el partido de macron y
sus mayores aliados tienen una mayoría
relativa pero pero no absoluta que que
le permitiría
adoptar ese proyecto Entonces
los republicanos del partido de derecha
del cual hablaba María José que es el
mayor partido de derecha en francés que
tienen 61 diputados tiene un papel clave
porque porque la mayoría de los
republicanos se declaran a favor de ese
proyecto Pero tenemos también una
fracción de de ese partido que que tiene
más más preguntas
en cuanto a este proyecto Entonces como
el gobierno no tenía
no tenía esa posibilidad o esa no era
seguro de poder tener una mayoría para
ha decidido adoptarlo justamente ese
artículo 471 que le permitía acceder a
la procedura en la asamblea y pasar el
proyecto en el senado después de de
discusión en la asamblea sin que haya
sido votado en totalidad en la asamblea
en el senado tenemos
las relaciones de fuerzas entre
diferentes partidos políticos están
diferentes porque los republicanos
tienen la mayoría
entonces normalmente ese proyecto sí
Debería ser
adoptado por
y después tenemos una otra fase que será
como una serie de negociación dentro de
una si esa comisión mixta paritaria y el
gobierno cuenta mucho Sobre esa comisión
justamente porque porque tiene que ir
unir
Cómo se dice paritaria tiene
tantos senadores que diputados
tienen tu cuenta de del estado de las
fuerzas entre esas dos instituciones
Entonces numéricamente debería ser
constituida de una mayoría de de
parlamentarios a favor de ese proyecto
porque la derecha del senado Debería ser
representada
en gran parte como los partidos que
están abiertos a macron en la asamblea
sí adelante
después tendrá que ser votado en la
asamblea y aquí el papel de los
republicanos después va a ser Va a ser
interesante porque porque de esos 60 y
unos diputados de los republicanos
depende la posibilidad
Esto será probado en el en el senado
cómo lo ve usted Esto va a trascender va
a lograr ser aprobado y se ve
transformada esta ley allí en Francia
usted qué análisis hace
yo creo que todavía la verdad es muy
temprano para tener este tipo de
análisis o querer prever si al final va
a pasar o no en la asamblea y pues luego
con los con Los en los diferentes
comités lo que sí creo Es que el
gobierno va a hacer todo lo posible para
que esta ley pase para que esta reforma
de pensiones tenga éxito y claro estamos
viendo que están buscando pues
diferentes
aliados en la derecha claro y no me
parece que quieran como querer negociar
con con otros sectores de la población
entonces realmente yo siento que es uno
de los proyectos bandera de macron
Entonces yo creo que
ya sea cualquier costo político social o
económico van a van a van a hacer todo
lo posible para que este proyecto de ley
pase bueno todo sin importar el costo
político esto cómo le pasa factura
Entonces al presidente María José Y a
quién beneficia este tipo de reformas
habrá sectores a los que les conviene
que este tipo de reformas sea aprobada
cuáles son
claro o sea definitivamente me parece
bastante como sorprendente un poco
extraño porque hemos visto que Manuel
macrona ha perdido cinco puntos de
popularidad estas últimas semanas
justamente por esta reforma entonces
siento que de cierta manera está claro
sacrificando su popularidad
en Pos de Pues de su credibilidad como
presidente porque pues esta fue una de
sus de sus promesas estándar en
dacampaña y claro se está jugando su
credibilidad y también su legado como
presidente porque bueno es la última vez
ya que que va a tener un gobierno aquí
en Francia y pues lo que las personas
están en general los que los analistas
aquí en Francia están hablando es que
claro se quiere vulnerar de nuevo a las
personas a los sectores de la población
que ya son vulnerables y que tienen una
vida bastante
difícil y claro y se vuelve a recordar
un poco que en el gobierno en el primer
gobierno de macron hubo una reducción de
los impuestos a lo a los más ricos
porque se suprimió el impuesto a la
fortuna Entonces se da como claro de
nuevo esta esta lógica de ayudar a
ciertas personas que pues ya tienen la
vida bastante Un poco más fácil y
precarizar más a las personas que viven
en condiciones de vulnerabilidad
su opinión sobre el precio que paga el
presidente macó por seguir adelante con
esta reforma a pesar del descontento
social
Sí es que voy a seguir un poco con lo
que decía María José pero si uno de los
argumentos que que
escuchamos más es esa idea que
justamente
esa reforma Viene un poco compensar
la reducción de los impuestos impuestos
de los más ricos que que adoptado el
gobierno de
y que justamente porque el crecimiento
económico no permite compensar la
reducción de impuestos los más ricos y
el aumento por ejemplo de la sección de
las acciones a los accionarios de de
grandes empresas
quiere hacer pesar ese esfuerzo en
mayoría en los empleos los más ingresos
o vulnerables
entonces
me parece que sí prácticamente
o sea es uno de los argumentos que
explica que la mayoría de la población
tiene que
rechaza esa claro esa reforma y más allá
la visión política y económica que que
está produciendo el gobierno de macron
María José Y qué hay de la oposición que
como vemos pues ha salido a manifestar
su rechazo también a esta coyuntura pero
estamos hablando de política y aquí no
se da puntada sin dedal la oposición
francesa como a capitalizado este
rechazo ciudadano este bajón en el en la
popularidad del presidente y Bueno este
descontento que se ve de manifiesto en
las calles en torno a esta reforma cómo
lo está capitalizando la oposición
política todo esto pensando obviamente
en votos a futuro
claro es la verdad es que bastante
Cómo decirlo un poco contradictorio
porque justamente en los últimos uno de
los últimos debates que hubo una
asamblea
la oposición que claro sería Francia
insumisa recibió bastante
No no recibió el respaldo de los
manifestantes de las personas de que
justamente que trabajan en en la en la
scf en las en la red de ferroviarias de
colectivos feministas etcétera no han
declarado de que no van a apoyar a este
partido de izquierda entonces parece que
no lo han capitalizado de la mejor
manera
su opinión sobre la oposición la la
parte política en todo esto
capitalizando Y aprovechando esta
coyuntura y este bajón de popularidad
del presidente de cara al futuro qué
piensa usted
es que lo he visto lo que he visto es
que pájaro rígidamente
la figura que que parece aprovechar más
de de esa secuencia
según las últimas encuestas encuestas de
opinión Perdón
Es más independiente es que justamente
no es la oposición la más activa en las
instituciones en la asamblea
especialmente en la asamblea
en contra de encontrar esa reforma
entonces parece que
ese derecho a su aumentar la popularidad
de ese partido aunque no no está muy
presente en la contestación de
de de esa reforma Entonces
sí sí parece que que queráis que ya
parlamentaria no no ha caracterizado
mucho en efecto
sobre ese derecho
para ir cerrando que ya vamos llegando
al bloque final de el programa desde la
parte de los sindicatos han ofrecido han
extendido la mano para algún tipo de
negociación con el gobierno o en este
caso el gobierno ha hecho oídos sordos a
todos estos reclamos y ha dejado pasar
estas jornadas de huelga Ya vamos por la
sexta Pero ha habido algún tipo de
ofrecimiento por parte de los sindicatos
he visto que o sea los sindicatos están
un poco divididos en
esa sobre Esa esa cuestión y la y la
posición adoptar
frente al gobierno Pero tenemos
el mayor sindicato que es la
confederación general de trabajo que
que no quiere hablar de negociación pero
que quiere
aumentar esa movilización hacia el
renunció a esa reforma tenemos otros
sindicatos como la
que que está a favor de una negociación
pero que lo que es interesante es que
parecen más
más en una posición de
oposición o de o de apoyo a una huelga
ilimitada que durante las otras
movilizaciones previas Entonces
sí parece que hay una
una división más fuerte entre la casi
totalidad de los sindicatos lo que
explica esta
intersindicalidad que que
se desarrolló durante durante esa y que
no logró existir durante aquellas
movilizaciones entonces claro
un par de minutos para finalizar el
programa María José ago las conclusiones
comienzo con usted lo que puede dejar
Entonces esta jornada y lo que se viene
para Francia en este extenso debate en
torno a esta nueva ley de jubilación
para este país europeo qué piensa usted
qué va a pasar siempre lo digo no
tenemos la bola de cristal para saber el
futuro pero desde su análisis que puede
suceder con
con esta ley con este proyecto
yo creo que de nuevo se evidencia
gracias a este proyecto de reforma de
pensiones de nuevo la desconexión de la
clase política gobernante con la
realidad vulnerable de de un sector de
la población y claro y qué se puede
esperar Pues de este de este proyecto de
reforma yo creo que como ya lo mencioné
que definitivamente yo creo que el
gobierno va a ser todo lo posible para
que este proyecto pasen asamblea para
que sea aprobado y para que a partir de
septiembre este nuevo régimen de
pensiones entre vigor pero también
confío bastante en la capacidad de de
los de estos sectores de la población
para mantenerse para mantener esta lucha
Y para poder mantener
para justamente para poder seguir
manifestando y parece justamente parece
interesante Cómo se están
Cómo se están como reagrupando y
rediseñando estas de estas
entrecruzamiento entre diferentes
sectores de la ciudadanía Y de nuevo Me
parece que claro a pesar del coste
político que esto genera macron hay
definitivamente una visión a largo plazo
y claro una visión cierta ambición a
nivel europeo para para Manuel macron
como como posible líder de una Unión
Europea su conclusión para el cierre
Sí sí estoy estoy de acuerdo con
con María José pensó que macron
quiere ir hacia
reforma porque es reforma
mayores la reforma que quiere adoptar
desde desde
la cual depende su credibilidad política
Porque
[Música]
pienso que es su aripé muchas veces que
que es la reforma necesaria por adoptar
también
estoy de acuerdo en el hecho de que
hace esa reforma para para tener el
crédito para descargar europea porque es
una reforma que ha sido
promocionada por la Unión Europea y las
europeos Pero en cuanto a las
movilizaciones sociales
movimientos sociales que que se
desarrollan en el marco de de esa de esa
secuencia es interesante de ver que
podemos podemos ver que hay nuevas
personas que antes no se movilizan no se
movilizaban que que está en la calle
también si podemos hablar de diferentes
sectores que
siguen que no tenía nada
se me acaba el tiempo avanzando tengo
que dejar ahí tengo que cortar su
intervención porque ya debo dar paso al
informativo Pero bueno este pulso entre
el gobierno y los sindicatos en Francia
ya va por esta sexta jornada de
manifestaciones vamos a ver hasta dónde
llega este pulso esta demostración de
fuerzas los secretarios generales de
diferentes
sindicatos han dicho que ha sido una
jornada histórica tal vez la mayor
movilización en los últimos 40 años en
Francia de parte del gobierno dicen que
mantienen su argumento es necesaria la
reforma de lo contrario
12.500 millones de euros serán Perdidos
anualmente por el sistema de pensiones
para el año 2030 de no hacer esta
modificación a María José avanzando les
agradezco mucho por haber estado con
nosotros en el programa en nombre de
todo el equipo técnico también les
agradezco su sintonía la producción del
programa estuvo a cargo de Laura garzón
y Luis Fernando Montes y la producción
de invitados estuvo a cargo de Tania
Herrera Pueden seguir dejando sus
comentarios a través de las redes
sociales Siguen con nosotros
[Música]